i had a guest actually come on this
podcast before jimmy carr jimmy carl was
on two weeks ago and we had a great
conversation about um happiness and the
nature of happiness and the guest before
jimmy carr wrote in my diary which is a
tradition we have now where all the
guests that come on write a question for
the next guest so there is a question
there for you but the guest wrote a
question um which changed his life which
is um are you happy and i from reading
your work and understanding your
position on happiness and it not being
the thing to aim for which really struck
me because i thought you know
i thought life was the north star of our
lives was to try and be happy i guess my
question is
what i was going to ask you that
question aim to be good and pray for
happiness
so the question i was going to is pretty
much that is what is a better question
for me to ask you if i'm checking in on
you because we asked that question with
good intentions are you happy what's a
better question for me to ask jordan
peterson
how are you doing
how are you doing hmm how are you doing
brilliantly and terribly
that's
you know when you listen to a profound
piece of music
one that sort of spans the whole
emotional experience
it's not happy
happy is elevator music and
probably you just shouldn't listen to
that at all right and and you think why
well
it's harmless it's trickly it's
sweet
uh
simple it lacks depth it's shallow
that's a problem
um
it doesn't have that deep sense of awe
and horror i would say
that is characteristic of the best of
all music
you know you listen to some mis simple
music so-called hank williams is a good
example you know the
blues cowboy from the 50s who died of
alcoholism when he was 27 and whose
voice sounds like an 80 year old man
simple melody you know but
there's nothing simple in the song and
and in the voice
it's deep you know it's like the blues
is it's like black blues in the states
from the 20s and this was certainly
influenced by that tradition
there's this
admission of a deep suffering
at the same time as
you get the
beautiful
transcendence of the music
and that's meaning you know that's
awful in the most fundamental sense but
you need an antidote to suffering and
it has to be deep and no one deep moves
you tectonically and it's not a trivial
thing
and but that's better than happiness
and maybe if you're lucky well you're
pursuing that and while you're immersed
in it you get to be happy and and you
should fall on your knees and be
grateful for that when it happens you
know it's a gift it really is a gift
and it comes upon you unexpectedly your
happiness you know
but
you aim to climb up hill to the highest
peak you can possibly envision
and that's
that's better than happiness
why did you include terribly
well for example now when i go
wherever i go in the world people come
up to me and they're
usually i wouldn't say they're happy to
see me
they're often in tears
you know
and they often have a pretty rough story
to relate you know they were suicidal or
nihilistic or homicidal or
trapped
desperate
you know and they tell me that real fast
and then they say i've overcome that to
a large degree and thank you for that
and
and you think well that's really
something to
have that happen over and over
in some ways you might think well how
could anything better possibly happen to
you and have people come up to you all
over the world strangers and open
themselves up like that like their old
friends so quickly but
at the same time it's an awful thing
because you see
even in the revelation of their triumph
the initial depth of their despair
so i wouldn't change that
but it's not nothing
and it's certainly not just happiness
it's better than happiness but it's
almost unbearable
god tears again
it's been quite a two weeks in the uk
it's been amazing
it's been amazing such a great country
this country
such a profound place and
was so wonderful to see
cambridge and oxford and
to be welcomed by the students and
i saw the queues around the block and
the reaction you got i watched the talk
in cambridge and
um it was so wonderful to see because it
you know i know that you don't do what
you do for credit that kind of seems to
be
the you know the antithesis of the
pursuing your truth and doing it
in the cause of truth but um it was so
wonderful to see someone that i know has
had such a profound impact on so many be
received in such a way we have a closing
tradition okay one of the you know i
don't do this but one of the really
great ceos in our country young guys
bought a multi-billion dollar company
really great guy sat here yesterday and
i actually told him for the first time
who he was writing the question for and
i couldn't believe his face oh my god
that's the one person i want to have
dinner with this is probably the most
successful young person in our country
and he was and so he knew who he was
writing the question for so the question
that the previous guest wrote
is for you is
why do you do
what you do
to see what will happen
some programs you you cannot predict
right you cannot predict how they're
going to end you have to run them
well you know i believe that truth will
save the world
i believe that
so you speak truthfully
and
you watch what happens and you take your
consequences
you know and maybe you hope and have
some faith that
in the final analysis
things will work out in your favor but
perhaps they will and perhaps they won't
but
that's faith they
that's faith it's faith isn't believing
in things you regard as ridiculous
sacrificing your intellect
it's
a decision you know will truth beauty
and love save the world
well you could find out
[Music]
you